yeah come on you you're good
yep i'm good
hi everyone
um
my name is sargon hostin i'm
here in the math department at san
francisco state university thanks for
being here this morning so we're going
to have two talks this morning in the
optimization on the
symmetry workshop in the fourth day um
rahman sanyal
from university of frankfurt from
germany is joining us this morning and
he's going to tell us about the
polyhedral geometry of pivot rules
all right
go ahead
all right thank you very much for the
introduction and thanks a lot for the
invitation can you hear me
all right
perfect so
also hello to everybody who is currently
at simon's let rest assured that i envy
every single one of you i was so much
looking forward to
to participating in the workshop in
person but uh
well
that's that's currently difficult
okay nevertheless i'm happy to
to um
well to tell you about a very exciting
project that is uh
i want to say coming to an end but
that's not true it turns out that this
project keeps on giving
this is about the polyhedral geometry of
pivot rules of
the simplex algorithm on linear programs
and i figured that it seems that i'm
i'm maybe even the one the only one
who's talking about linear programming
and linear optimization
in the whole workshop
okay so this is um joint work with alex
black and jesus delaware who are both at
uc davis and nicholas luthier harms who
is a
master student here in frankfurt
although he's currently in barcelona
so
let me get into the topic i want to talk
about linear programs and the simplex
algorithm and
explain or give a new perspective on
um
pivot rules and well
hopefully then running times at at some
point in the future of the simplex
algorithm so
let me set it up set the stage so i a
linear program or lp for short is i
optimize a linear function given by some
vector c
and i optimize it over all such x that
satisfy a finite system of linear
inequalities that i denote by ax small
or equal to b
um this is a class of uh i guess it's a
waste of breath to to explain to tell
you that linear programs are
important and used in
uh well in everyday applications
and one of the oldest and still very
important
method to solve a linear program is the
simplex method which is not
really an
algorithm but more of a more a whole
framework of algorithms that solve an lp
but the magic ingredients for
for an actual implementation
is the pivot rule that
i'll explain a little bit more in a
second
and you have to supply the feasible
basis so you have to give it a starting
point and from there on it will try to
find a maximal
solution to the linear program
um i'm more of a geometer and less of an
optimizer so i the perspective that i
want to offer
on the simplex algorithm is a
is from a geometer's point of view
so i want to think about the constraints
the linear inequalities the solution set
to the system of linear inequalities as
a polyhedron so a bounded sorry a
polytope so a bounded polyhedron there
is no harm in assuming that it is
bounded
the
linear objective function provided it is
generic will supply a unique optimal
solution
to this i should have said non-empty
polytope
sorry to the linear program so there is
at least one feasible solution and there
will be a unique
optimal solution but if my objective
function is sufficiently generic
then no two vertices of the polytope
will have the same value
and this gives me an orientation on the
graph of the polytope like here on the
cube
where i orient every edge from the
towards the vertex with the larger value
with respect to c
then
sorry the simplex method is
what it does is it follows a vertex edge
path from my starting vertex for example
this
green vertex down here it follows a path
by moving along edges from vertex to
vertex
until it reaches the unique optimal
solution so the sink
of this unique sync orientation
and
along
the this path the simplex method has to
make choices so for example at this
vertex it decided to go up instead of to
to take the other outgoing edge at that
vertex
and this choice is guided by the pivot
rule so the pivot rule tells me
what vertices i choose
along the path
um there are many
different pivot rules um
that have been proposed over the years
one among the oldest one is the greatest
improvement pivot rule which for a
non-sink vertex so if your vertex
at which you're at is not the
unique optimum then what it does it it
chooses among um
the neighbors of v one that
maximizes the improvement so that it
maximizes the the improvement of
of the linear function and
as as long as v is not the unique
optimum there will always be a neighbor
with which have a better which has a
better valve
um
something is not working that great okay
so um and
another pivot rule that is very popular
in practice is the steepest edge pivot
rule which is similar to the greatest
improvement but instead of looking just
at what is the improvement along
the edge or to the neighbor it chooses
the neighbor that has the
largest unit increase
and the unit here is given
by typically
the l2 norms or the euclidean norm but
there are also variants that use
different norms in particular
lp norms
in order to to normalize
the increase along an edge
there
another
pivot rule that is very popular is the
shadow vertex rule which is a little bit
more involved to explain but very very
powerful
and the way it works is that instead of
considering your high dimensional
polytope you choose a
suitably choose a two-dimensional
projection which turns your polytope
into a polygon
the star and you choose the projection
in that way so that the starting vertex
here v
and the optimal vertex v opt will be
vertices of the two-dimensional
projection
cam we're not seeing your
the the the figure that you're trying to
point
really no
but why now it's there now it's the oops
yeah it's there yeah now we can see it
but i think we were seeing some parts uh
and some parts are probably missing so
if you don't mind going back 30 seconds
and
working with this figure that might be
yeah right
right so i don't know what the problem
is if if you see me pointing at
something that's not there please
interrupt
okay so now you see the figure the
shadow vertex rule as i try to explain
is
it uses two-dimensional projections so
you have your starting vertex v here you
have your optimal vertex
v opt over there and what the shadow
vertex rule does it it chooses a
suitable two-dimensional projection
suitable in the sense that the image of
v is a vertex and the image of v opt is
also a vertex
of this two-dimensional polytope
on this polygon it's clear how to move
from that vertex to the optimal vertex
and if the projection is sufficiently
generic then this red path down here
will uniquely lift to an edge path
on the high dimensional polytope and
this is precisely the
path that the simplex algorithm takes
for the shadow vertex rule
so
i said the important bit is to choose a
suitable two-dimensional projection i
will say a bit more
about that in a couple of slides
but uh the two-dimensional projection is
given by well two linear functions one
of which will be the objective function
c which will make sure that the image
of uh v opt is a vertex
but we need also make sure that the
image of v is a vertex and for this you
have to choose some auxiliary linear
function w that you will have to choose
depending on your starting vertex fee
okay so these are three
pivot rules there are many more for
example
uh norman zades least entered facet rule
and
many more all of which as far as we know
have exponential running times so for
each and every
pivot rule um
well okay that's probably a bit daring
to say that but for many of the more
popular pivot rules there examples have
been found that
for which the simplex algorithm requires
an expanded exponential number of steps
so the path will get long depending on
on your starting vertex v
and
the i guess the holy grail of linear
optimization at least in some version is
to find
a version of the simplex algorithm that
runs in polynomially many steps
so
i want to understand what
pivot rules do on a given linear program
um and in order to do that what i can i
i don't want to fix the starting vertex
so in order to to see what the simplex
algorithm does with a fixed pivot rule i
can look at its footprint which is just
the collection of all simplex paths for
all starting vertices v
and here are three examples and you
notice a difference and i don't mean the
color
so
these two examples they are
uh then the um red colored edges they uh
constitute an adversary so a directed
tree with root at the
unique sink
whereas this is well it looks like a
collector it's the union of
of path
and the difference is that
um
certain pivot rules are what we call
memoryless so they only
make choices based on the local
information that
is provided at a given vertex
so it does not remember where the path
started or what the previous vertices
along the path are
it just makes the choice
um locally at at a given vertex it
chooses one outgoing edge and since the
orientation is acyclic it will
[Music]
the footprint will correspond to an
other assets
so greatest improvement and steepest
edge the way that i've shown them on the
previous slide they make local choices
right so at every vertex they choose
either the the neighboring vertex the
improving neighboring vertex with
um
with the largest improvement or the with
the largest unit improvement
but sade's rule and the
at least the version of the shadow
vertex rule that i've shown on the
previous slide they are not memoryless
in the sense there's a question in the
chat
[Music]
okay
not sure but that's not a question for
me
all right so sadness rule and and the
original shadow vertex rule are not
memoryless so remember the shadow vertex
rule it
it chooses a path in the two-dimensional
projection and so this path is already
determined once i've chosen
this two-dimensional projection and so
there is no local choice that is made
in every
at every step
um
the other essence are not only a good
way to to visualize
the pivot rule at least in small and low
dimensions
but it also encodes the complete
behavior of the given pivot rule on the
fixed lp right so if i want to emulate
the simplex algorithm from any starting
vertex then the
these two red upper essences they
provide sufficient information to run
the simplex algorithm i just follow
the path that is provided by the other
essence
and
in this sense
i can use our essences to to address the
two main questions that that we wanted
to look into in in the project namely
how do our essences or pivot rules
change
sorry our residences change when we fix
the objective function and we vary the
pivot rule
and how do the other essences change
when we fix the pivot rule and we vary
the objective function c so the latter
question is related to a parametric
linear programming that i will say more
about
later but the formal one is
[Music]
is to the best of our knowledge new
because we don't look at individual
pivot rules but we want to study
families of pivot rule that we get by
changing the pivot rule in a continuous
manner
that means that the next thing that i
need to explain is how do i so what do i
mean by changing pivot rules in a
continuous manner and
and what does the space of of pivot
rules then then look like
all right so i didn't say that at the
beginning but of course stop stop me and
ask question if if you have one
and uh
maybe i pause for a few seconds to see
whether there is a question
somewhere
there is a question just sick
right
uh maybe this is a silly question in the
shadow vertex rule you said like you're
picking a projection to make the optimum
be a vertex of the 2d thing
but you don't know where the optimum is
right
i don't but i don't need to i so the
only important thing is that i know that
with respect to the two-dimensional
projection there will be a vertex that
er that is
that will lift to the unique optimal
vertex
but you're like are you searching for a
path
to something
i'm searching for a path to something
that's for sure
like what is that thing if you don't
know where the album is
um
let me
uh let me defer your question to uh to a
little bit later i i explain how to find
how to find the shadow vertex path in a
little bit all right no worries thank
you
all right um
anything else
okay so where where are we at i want to
focus on memoryless pivot rules
that make the
that make the
pivoting
choices based on local information
and i want to
introduce next the class of pivot rules
where i can change them in a continuous
manner and i want to then see how do the
average senses change if i vary the
pivot rule and i want to see how the our
senses change when i fix the pivot rule
but i vary the objective linear function
okay so
what we introduce
is what uh we what we call the
normalized weight pivot rules or nw
rules for short so if i if i'm given a
non-empty polytope p and an objective
function c
i choose based on the polytope and the
objective function a normalization eta
and a weight w
and for every non
optimal of for every non-sync vertex i
determine the next vertex on the simplex
path according to that rule
and this rule is
is somewhat uh um
well it's a generalization of the
greatest improvement and the steepest
edge rule i'll say say that again in a
second
i choose the neighboring vertex that
maximizes the
the linear function or the the increase
with respect to the linear function w
and i normally uh normalized by the
function
so this should explain what we call
either the normalization
and
well it does not explain why we call w
the weight but maybe i get to that
the choice of eta and w is as i said
made with respect to p and c
so
it's not that i fix the normalization
and the weight but i choose i
i'm allowed to choose it
given the polytope and the objective
function c
so for example
what is wrong
okay
so for example for greatest improvement
there is no normalization so i set the
normalization to be eager to be constant
one
and for the weight i choose the linear
function c and then this formula turns
into i choose the
neighboring vertex that has a bigger c
value and that maximizes the improvement
so that's exactly greatest improvement
for steepest edge i would choose the
normalization to be
the the norm for example the euclidean
norm but as i said p norm works as well
and for the weight i would again choose
c and if i plug this in in what is
written up here then
it is exactly the steepest edge so i
look at the increase in the linear
function
um
normalized with respect to
to the length of the edge
so many important pivot rules turn out
to be nw rules including the shadow
vertex rule uh which at least not well
in a in a slight modification that i
that i explained in a little bit
and this makes uh normalized weight
rules uh and a nice and big class to
study
um but we
but we don't get all the memoryless
pivot rules right so
normalized weight rules are form a
strict subset of the memoryless rules so
first of all
normalized weight rules they are
memoryless
just follows from the definition i for
every vertex the choice that i make is
is really just
the local information given by the edge
directions
but that since i only use the edge
direction this also gives
shows that there is a certain limitation
so for example this arborescence on the
three cube can never be obtained
from a normalized weight pivot rule
because at this vertex
and i'm just
double checking you see a
three-dimensional cube on my slides you
do all right
so at this vertex i see i have three
outgoing edges
and at this vertex i have two outgoing
edges and this edge direction or this
edge vector is exactly the same as this
edge vector and this edge vector is
exactly the same as this edge vector and
since this definition here only depends
on the edge vectors
if i choose among these three edge
vectors this one that goes
to the back of the cube
then at this point here i would also
have to choose the one that goes to the
back instead of the one that goes up
because well i had to make a choice
between these two already at this vertex
here
and
since this is not the case in this red
arborescence this red adversaries cannot
come from a normalized weight roof
however it's not so bad
namely that
normalized weight rules are universal in
the following sense so for every simple
polytope so meaning that um that the
the polytope or the linear program is
non-degenerate
there will always be a suitable
perturbation such that every memoryless
pivot rule or so that every memoryless
pivot rule can be
uh simulated by an nw rule right i said
differently for every memoryless pivot
rule on this particulation there will be
some nw rule that will produce the same
collection of our essences
so the same arborescence for every given
objective functions
and from a combinatorial point of view
this is so from a practical point of
view this is not so bad perturbing is is
nothing that uh uh
is what computers are doing anyways
but from a geometric point of view this
is also not so bad because simple
polytopes they are
invariant under perturbation at least
the combinatorial structure stays intact
so we don't lose much so means that if
we
restrict to sufficiently generic
polytopes then we will
see the behavior of every
memoryless pivot rule already on some
normalized wave
so the normalized weight rule has the
advantage that i have two parameters
that i choose namely the normalization
and the weight and in particular the
weight is something that i can vary in a
nice and continuous fashion so if i fix
my linear program
p c and i fix a normalization then every
generic weight w will give me an upper
essence and so the rule that we saw
that um
provides an adverseness so for every non
sink vertex i choose the
the the outgoing edge or the the
neighboring vertex among the improving
ones on
as i said an outgoing edge
uh with respect to that rule and for the
uh the on the only vertex where i don't
have to choose anything is the optimum
so this allows us to change pivot rules
in a continuous manner right so i fixed
the normalization and i vary uh w in um
as i wish
and this defines a map that for every w
gives me an arborescence
for the fixed linear program p and c and
for this fixed linear for the fixed
normalization
and in particular
this
map parameterizes the family of
memoryless pivot rules on this i think
there are some stuff from the slides
that we're not seeing so can you
move a little bit
yeah that's better now okay okay
it's a little annoying
okay
um
so what i said
and where i pointed at all the all the
time was that i can now change pivot
rules in a continuous fashion
for every w generic sufficiently generic
i get a i get an arborescence
and in particular this parametrizes a
family of memoryless pivot rules on this
fixed linear program and so i can
ask
which adore essences
can arise
on this fixed linear program for a fixed
normalization and what is the collection
of all w that for example yield the same
averages
and just for
um nomenclature let me call an
oberessence on
the linear program p comma c coherent if
it arises from this fixed normalization
with respect to some w
let me see this slide one more time
is it big
yeah yes that's better yeah
okay
do you mind if i just
take 30 seconds off and try to switch
the
um
let me just briefly switch the
to a different viewer this is uh
i rather
yeah
what are you using roman acrobat reader
i thought this is good
this is windows or mac
that's a mac
all right i just need to find
okay
can you see my slides
yes
okay let me not start over
okay good so i was here so i can
vary the avarescence in a continuous
manner or the pivot rule in a continuous
manner so the two questions that arise
naturally are which arborescens can i
get for a fixed
normalization
by changing w and which collection of w
will give me the same advancements and i
want to call an upper essence on
the polytope p with its
oriented graph with respect to the
linear function c coherent if i can find
some w
that gives me exactly that other
all right
we're on the same page
good
so the result that we proved is that
there is a polytope that we call the
pivot polytope or the pivot rule
polytope with respect of four
the linear program p and c and with the
fixed normalization ether
that has the property that
two
generic weights w and w prime will give
me the same oborescence if and only if
they
give me the same vertex or phase on the
pivotal polytope
so in brief this means that there's a
whole polytube worth of adverseness for
a fixed linear program p
comma c
and this means that the aberrances or
yeah the behavior of the simplex
algorithm with respect to the family of
nw rules given by
the fixed eater and changing w has the
nice structure it is captured by the
combinatorics of some
honest and
nice polytope
and this gives us a lot of structure so
for example we can
study the sensitivity and in particular
the number of different arborescences
that we get on a non-degenerate linear
program so again non-degenerate linear
program
means that the polytope p is simple
and for the simple polytope we can
for the fixed linear function c count
the number of
vertices with in degree i or the number
of vertices of the polytope that have
exactly dimension of p minus i outgoing
edges and this turns out to be
independent of c
and a previous paper adenosinedes jesus
and a phd student of of resources they
studied the number of other essences
that you can get in total which is
this well large number
in terms of the
in terms of the numbers h i
but for our coherent our essences we get
a
a smaller or well more refined upper
bound in terms of the d minus first
elementary symmetric function
and we get this from the
geometric perspective namely that the
polytope that i
introduced on the previous slide turns
out to be a minkowski sum
of
simple polytopes of simplices and then
we can use
geometric results on the complexity of
well general minkowski sums that gives
us the upper bound
okay so
it means we we get polytopes that um
represent the
well the geometry and the combinatorics
of nw rules so what are these polytopes
like
and before i do that let me uh make up
for my promising ex and and
well explaining shadow vertex rule a
little bit more thoroughly and thereby
introducing a generalization which then
turns out to be
memoryless
namely what i said before is that if i
have my fixed linear program p comma c
and a starting vertex w then what i can
do is i choose some
some auxiliary linear function
sorry i have my vertex v and i choose an
auxiliary
another linear function w that is
maximized by v
this defines a linear projection
which turns my high dimensional polytope
into a polygon
and the way that i've chosen
w means that the projection of
v is a vertex of the polygon and the
projection of the unknown optimal vertex
v opt will also be a vertex of the
projection i don't know which one but i
can find it by
starting at
the projection of v and then following
the increasing c coordinate
and decreasing um the slope of the edge
that i take
starting at pi of v
and i don't know who asked that question
in the audience but i hope this at least
gives a
give some sort of an answer i don't know
where the optimal value is
sorry i don't know where the optimal the
projection of the optimal vertex is but
i can still find it by just making local
steps i in the projection i choose
outgoing edges improving c and
decreasing in slow
good
all right
so if i explain it in this way
i
automatic or i immediately well not
immediately but i hope i can convince
you that i can generalize this rule of
taking maximal slopes uh to all vertices
namely
if i not look at the projection of the
whole polytope but just of the graph
then
this will be a mess it will look a
little bit like this
but every if i zoom in on every
individual vertex then i see a point
from which there will be edges emanating
some of which in the increasing
direction of c and some of them in the
decreasing direction of c
but among the vertices among the edges
that emanate from this vertex here there
will be one that has the largest slope
and
i can pick this edge from this vertex
and since i assume that my projection is
generic this vertex here well no sorry
this
doesn't this here does not have anything
to do with gene genericity of projection
since this vertex comes from a vertex
uh of my original poly two p and these
edges are also edges of my original
polygon p i just chose
an outgoing edge of this vertex
in p and this defines
a memoryless pivot rule
namely
for every vertex v
i look at all the improving neighbors
and i
choose the
though and the neighbor that has the
largest slope in this two dimensional
projection and the slope of this
direction is just given by the quotient
of
w of u minus v
uh relative to c
um
of w minus uh u minus
u minus v
all right
so this gives me
a memoryless pivot rule or an actually
nw rule
that
in particular we'll have this path here
from pi of v to pi of v opt
so what this says is that the max slow
pivot rule generalizes the vertex
shadow vertex rule
and is therefore a memoryless
generalization of shadow vertex
so the original shadow vertex rule does
not
qualify as a as a memoryless
pivot rule but this max slope rule which
generalizes it is memoryless because i
only make choices locally if i want in
this two-dimensional
picture okay
so
um
this max slope and in particular shadow
vertex has a relation to what is just a
second is a question
i am
[Music]
um okay now now i have a question about
the shadow vertex so when you when you
do this projection now
um
so you're doing this projection only
with respect to your current vertex
right and then you decide to just take
to walk towards the optim the projection
of the optimal in a neighbor vertex
and then at every step you choose a w
is that correct no that's not correct in
the original shadow vertex rule you
choose one w and this w will give you
that this two-dimensional projection
and from this you will determine the we
go back
it will determine this red path in the
two-dimensional picture
oh so you go with this projection and
then you just keep
looking at the facets on the top and
then trying to figure out which
other vertex gives me the projection and
then you just look at and then you keep
going but with the same projection oh
okay okay the problem is that in this
original version
i don't for example for this vertex here
at the bottom i don't get i don't
get information how i would walk along a
simplex path
right because it is not the vertex that
is maximized by
by
the second coordinate in the projection
right in particular all the vertices
that land in the interior of this
two-dimensional polygon they also don't
get any information how would i proceed
from that vertex zone and this is why we
do this generalization so instead of
looking at the polygon we look at the
projected graph if you want
and locally at every vertex there will
be outgoing edges and every edge has a
slope and we for every vertex we pick
the edge with the
maximal slope
with respect to the two-dimensional
projection and then formulas this is
exactly that oh okay so then i have
another question so why do we care about
the
interior points in this poly in this
polygon that you have because can't we
just if we use pivot rules like can we
not always select
uh from don't we know that there's
always a neighbor of v
such that pi of v will go to the next
one like between pi of v and pi evolved
or no
i'm not sure i understand the question
um so the the way that i introduced
pivot rules or the pivot rules that i
want to worry about is that i don't
really care what the starting vertex is
so it could be any of the vertices
the shadow vertex rule would choose a
suitable
projection for every single of these of
these vertices but this would mean that
the individual path that i get they
don't have much to do with each other
in this generalization here it does not
really matter
what vertex you start with
because for every single one you would
get a choice of an outgoing edge
oh i see because you don't necessarily
choose you are not necessarily in v to
begin with you just choose a double and
you know that there's a v that's
maximized but you might as well like of
course as usual your w will be
such that whatever vertex you're in
you'll be inside of this polygon to
begin with
okay so let me say that one more time if
i so if we can agree on a v
then i have to choose some suitable w
um to in order to run shadow vertex
but here i don't need to
choose the uh i don't need to choose a
different w for every vertex
but i can still
get
or
get a memoryless pivot rule in the sense
that for every vertex i will make a
deterministic choice
and only need to look at local
information yeah yeah i guess yeah i get
my my confusion is that you don't have v
to begin with then you start in the
middle and then after that i agree
everything thanks
so of course it's a
different way to to to
to interpret your question is why why
would you care about other vertices
anyways why not just be content with
the v that you have up here and follow
the path
but
there are different ways in which this
this path show up and one of them is the
theory of monotone path all right
so i have my linear function on p let me
minimize it instead of maximize it and
since c is a generic linear function
there will be a unique vertex v minus
opt that will minimize the linear
function over p
i can still do the two dimensional
projection namely i get this projection
of v up here i get the optimal vertex
with respect to maximizing c and i get
the optimal vertex with respect to
minimizing c
and there will be a unique monotone path
that runs in the upper half plane if you
want
and that walks from v minus opt to v opt
along the uh well the upper side of this
polygon
this is what is called a monotone path
of p with respect to c it goes from the
minimal vertex to the maximal vertex and
it takes an increase c increasing
path in the
in the graph of p
and it turns out that these monotone
paths they are important and interesting
so for example they were studied by
belera and stormfells when they
considered um or when they introduced
fiber polytopes and uh and which
generalized
um
regular subdivisions
but this monotone path in particular
they could hear in monotone path they
gained more interest in in connection to
well higher homophobia theory where they
correspond to cellular strings on
polytopes that's related to loop spaces
and h spaces
um
[Music]
and in particular to bowsposets
showed that these monotone path
polytopes they captured the topology of
cellular strings
um and does give the the right or
give the homotopy type or give a
representation of the homophobic type of
the powers possible
so
what
we
found
is that our pivot polytops for the max
slope they refine the monotone path
polytopes and if you think about that
this is actually
quite plausible
because the monotone path polytope it
looks at monotone path
from the minimal vertex to the maximal
vertex whereas our pivot rule polytopes
for max slope they look at diff a path
from all of its vertices right so
morally the right generalization of a
monotone path is an arborist sense that
um
that takes the role of or that
represents a pivot rule on p with
respect to c
do you think you'll be wrapping up in
five minutes or so five six minutes
uh
i have to i guess
all right
um
yeah i will be wrapping up at five or
six minutes all right
um
thanks for the question
um
so the pivot rule polytops and they
refine their monotone path polytopes
in the sense of minkowski sums so they
give
[Music]
the underlying fan is a coarsening
although i won't say much about that and
there are particular cases when they are
the same
um
even though i'm running out of time out
of time fast let me still try to briefly
give you this simplex example the silly
play of word so the the simplest example
that we wanted to look at was the
simplex where
optimization is not really challenging
but it's still not so clear how the our
senses change
so there are d factorial many arbor
senses for a fixed linear function c but
not all of them are coherent so here for
the tetrahedron there will be six hour
sensors but only five of them coherent
with respect to max slope
and what we figured out is that the
forbidden substructure in these upper
sensors are these crossings so you're
not supposed to have a crossing so all
the
coherent upper sensors of a simplex with
respect to the max slope rule they are
non-crossing and this non-crossing
condition helps you to count them
and it turns out they are catalan many
of them
and if you
know well
if you are
a big fan of catalan
objects then um you know the isosahedron
which turns up in topology and uh which
is a very famous polytopic it turns out
that the max slow pivot rule polytope of
the simplex is exactly
an incarnation of star chefs as a sage
um
so there are other examples that i guess
i don't have time to go into
but there are many
interesting and important
examples from geometric combinatorics
that show up and that i'm happy to tell
you about later but let me at least say
a few words about the second question
that i that i advertised at the
beginning namely parametric linear
programming is i fix the constraints and
i want to to see how much can i change
my objective function without losing my
optimal vertex
so the obvious refinement in our setting
is that how much can we change c without
changing the
behavior of the pivot rule so without
changing the other essence
so for in order to do that we need to to
make two assumptions namely that the
normalization is independent
of c so it does not change if we change
c
and what is also um
well let's say in some sense natural to
to assume is that the weight that we use
is exactly the objective function
then this is the rule that i showed you
earlier but by the choice of the weight
we don't really need to worry about the
improving neighbors
and this gives
again
in our essence
and
we get a similar theorem namely that
uh there is a poly total worth of
adversaries that we get by fixing the
normalization and changing the objective
function
so we get again that
the other essences for changing
objective function they are
parameterized by the vertices of the
very nice part
this again gives us a possibility to um
to well to understand numbers and and
more of a sensitivity
um
let me see whether i want to say that
probably not it turns out that
there's an interesting connection to
orbit polytopes with respect to
reflection groups
where they
combinatorially relate to something very
classic namely order types and
admissible
permutations that were introduced by
goodman and [ __ ]
and polytopes that have been studied in
a number of different contexts
uh most recently by philippe
and patrol in the in the perspective of
sweet polytopes and we can again get
refinements and equivalences for certain
well so for certain types of groups
um
let me not tell you about the greedy
structures and instead
wrap up so what i tried to tell you
and didn't do it in a
let's say in a timely fashion
is i wanted to convince you that
memoryless pivot rules
are nice
and get you
get you basically all the
important and interesting rules on
linear programs
that you
that uh normalized weight pivot rules
give a way to continuously parametrize
pivot rules in particular all memoryless
on
suitable perturbations
that the change in essence or change in
behavior of the pivot rule um is
governed by two interesting polytopes
the pivot rule polytope and the naval
tope that whose geometry allows us to
give numbers on
or bounds on the number of coherent
overessences
and to
uh
yeah
they these polytops they make prominent
appearances outside optimization more in
the algebraic and geometric
combinatorics part
i hope i didn't go too badly over time
let me thank you for
uh
yeah for listening
thanks roman thank you
so um we have time for questions so
anymore
yes
um
so uh one question that i have is
is there any
um
[Music]
are there any kind of computational
directions uh i mean this geometry is
really nice and beautiful i think it's
uh
is there any way to relate all those
objects now uh to computational
complexity of the simplex for those
pivot rules or
i guess my honest answer is we don't
know yet
so it would be
very interesting to to understand more
about how though the abrara senses
change
and for example to to see whether we can
recover
some of them
for example the smooth analysis of the
shadow vertex rule from this new
perspective
so do for example uh changing the the
two-dimensional projection
or how much do i have to change the
two-dimensional projection so that
shadow vertex suddenly runs fast on bad
examples
uh and another question is uh
okay and even for like do you know that
even let's say for a solved problem even
for the bad examples where we know like
the the pivot rules and that they take
like uh exponential like complexity do
you know like can you also explain
through the geometry like why
like can you see through the geometry
side like why would that be the case as
well can you give a different proof of
the
of the lower bounds that we have for the
different one for the examples of people
rules that we know
um
no
i don't i don't think so because they
s so for the bad examples is basically
for every for every pivot rule i can
construct one example
but our
perspective says that we
we get whole families of of pivot rules
so what would be interesting for example
is there maybe a class of polytops that
would run
uh would take um
exponentially exponential time on the
whole family of of pivot rules
parameterized by the weights
i don't know did my answer make sense
so we don't look at individual pivot
rules but families
so what we could look at is that how
much
um
how much can we how much do we have to
change a pivot rule and all so that the
bad example is not bad anymore
but the question would be so the
interesting question would be is can we
find bad examples for a whole family of
nw rules
ramon there is a question in the chat
in the chat yes
could one hope to sample efficiently
from the pivotal polytope and prove an
expected
running time bound that would be so um i
think um
sampling shouldn't be so bad but prove
an expected running time bound that
would be great but i have no idea how
and none of my co-authors at least is
is
i guess they're all
participating via youtube
not sure whether they would have a more
to say about that
i have one quick question
sorry except somebody else has the
question first
that's really a non-expert question so
let's suppose you would put some kind of
ensemble on this
rectangular matrix a that defines the
polytope
what would you know about the
distribution of these graphs which arise
in your
i mean these edge graphs
is there is that is that something
that's understood let's say when of
course for large dimensions
and for a large dimension of x and an
even larger dimension of constraints
we think of some random matrix a
and what can you say about the
the graph
which
arises
the statistics
then it's a random graph and
can you characterize its statistics
i have no
idea think
i think that the question is maybe a
little bit too broad right so if you
if you start with a specific matrix and
you're looking at random perturbations
then depending on your um on your
distribution nothing might change
because you you start with a simple
polytope and simple polytops mean that
you can arbitrarily
change or perturb the entries
uh in a small radius without changing um
the combinatorics
yeah it's a it's a great question but i
i
i guess we would have to get a little
bit more specific and then the the
probability is still high that i'd say i
have no idea
so i maybe i have asked the last
question
um so you when you look at this uh you
have this pivot polytope and you
mentioned uh
and it went fast you know but uh the
connections to the
the uh monotone path polar top right the
pillar and stream fuzz
so of course that's a fiber polar tube
my earlier question is going to be
before you even mention those things is
that anything that relates the pivot
polytop to the secondary polar top of
your
of p
is there anything
um
um
that we can learn from the
from this polar tube about the
triangulations or
from the triangulations polished up to
the pivot position
i'd say not yet
so
we have some ideas of generalizing fiber
polytopes in the way that we generalize
the
monotone path polytopes
let me maybe sidewind your question so
monotone path polytopes are interesting
but they're complicated to
compute
in particular the computation is
i'd say
global in some sense you take your
polytope and you
need to take slices so this is always a
so you need to cut your your polytope by
a hyperplane and this gives you this is
pretty global
the definition of our
pivot polytopes is local so we get a
local contribution at every vertex
and this is something that we still try
to
to understand better
so we have the proof but it doesn't mean
that doesn't mean that we that we fully
understand our result
why the local contributions give you a
polytope that carries
uh at least as much information as
the monotone path polytope which is as i
said defined by by
by more global information
any other questions
okay doesn't look like there are more
questions thank you rahman for your
lunch yes
um and our next talk is going to be half
hour so at 11 o'clock we have the second
talk of the morning session see you then
you